[Musique]
alors que plusieurs d'entre nous met la
touche finale aux décorations c'est
l'heure du bilan de fin d'année pour les
producteurs d'arbres de noël
une année qui avait bien mal commencé
mais qui se termine sur une note festive
[Musique]
et mr gago
début novembre la période de l'année la
plus occupée chez les producteurs de
sapins de noël à maillezais sa lettre
poursuit j'ai jamais connu 135 même un
thé producteurs on s'appelle pour avoir
des dés et moi s'ils restent des arbres
train d'être gérald couture est un des
pionniers de la production d'arbres de
noël au pays
la sapinière familiale située à
courcelles en estrie est en opération
depuis 65 ans la totalité de sa récolte
est destinée à l'exportation
surtout vers les îles des caraïbes le
tropical au fonds servant à antigua le
si beau ici je vais l'envoyer aux îles
caïmans et le tropical qui sont en train
de finir ça va saint martin c'est ma
clientèle ces 75 % de ma business
pourtant malgré cette frénésie de fin
d'année 2020 annoncés rien donc toutes
les îles des caraïbes le nord de
l'amérique du sud venezuela l'amérique
centrale un peu partout on a peu à peu
près 20 ou 25% de la baie de nice à
l'exportation la grosse raison c'est le
virus il n'y a pas de touristes les
économies sont beaucoup moins bonnes
au panama son principal client
plusieurs hôtels et commerces ont fermé
cette année ce sont ces établissements
qui règle générale acheter des certains
québécois
normalement la marche et énormément de
premium sept à huit pieds avec une
étiquette rouge cette année avec
l'économique et
de moins bonnes qu'avant pour acheter
plus d'armes de deuxième classe donc au
lieu d'avoir des t bonds dans leur
assiette bio du boeuf haché mais son
marché vers les états unis qui occupent
habituellement 15 à 20% de son carnet de
commandes s'est révélé sa planche de
salut en cette saison pourtant pina le
parti de l'évent bessanaise il puise là
pour ces américains sont arrivés puis
ils sont aperçus qu'elle va pas d'arbres
qu'il ils manquent pas le prix averse
était le prix puis maintenant c'est une
question de prix
[Musique]
à l'origine de cette pénurie de sapin
chez nos voisins du sud
le manque de relève dans les plantations
mais aussi les nombreux épisodes de
sécheresse et de feux de forêt qui ont
dévasté des cultures entières dans les
états producteurs comme le rayon et la
caroline du nord
ça a été vraiment donné le ca a changé
tout au long de l'année pour votre cas
pas de planter mozart benjamin cdapp
pour fournir et comme si les aléas des
marchés n'était pas suffisant
l'arrivée tardive et incertaine des
travailleurs étrangers au printemps est
venu ajouter à l'inquiétude des
producteurs de pays nous a été de penser
qu'on aurait pas nos travailleurs pour
la plantation et la récolte
j'ai des goûts comme anastacio savait et
d'un guide 6 millions ça car ils veulent
qu'on
ça fonctionne bien jacky la première
normalement
c'était l'enfer de on savait pas s'ils
allaient arriver
l'exemple est du mexique a et on va le
savoir nos papiers jaj aucune idée on
n'a aucune façon d'avoir des
renseignements ce désarroi des
producteurs
charles vaillancourt l'entendue et il a
craint le pire pour l'industrie en cette
saison 2020 les gens fantin peu plus à
un niveau de panique et un sentiment
d'urgence de voir qu'est ce qui va se
passer là avec avec nos travailleurs la
saison s'amorce et on devait planter les
jeunes pousses tailler les arbres
matures et se préparer pour la récolte
les semaines passées et la pression
monte cette période d'incertitude a duré
près de deux mois
on devait toujours être capable de
regarder la distanciation devant les
maisons donc pour certains ça a été
possible d'autres ont dû loger leurs
travailleurs à l'hôtel lorsque c'est
encore plus coûteux puis 1 2 semaines le
pas c'est pas évident de trouver des
chambres d'hôtel en bois sans d'alors
partout
il y actuellement 260 deux producteurs
de sapins de noël au québec
c'est ici dans ces vallons de l'estrie
qu'on trouve le plus grand nombre de
plantations pays les sapinières
québécoise contribue d'ailleurs à plus
de 70% des exportations canadiennes
près de deux millions et demi de ces
conifères sont vendus chaque année
c'est presque deux fois plus qu'il ya
cinq ans
[Musique]
on va essayer de couper alentours de 110
à 150 mille arbres par année
charles vaillancourt et de la troisième
génération producteurs sur sa plantation
à stanstead dans les cantons de l'est
son marché c'est les états unis cela
représente 80% de sa production
le reste est destiné au marché canadien
un marché de plus en plus exigeants les
gens sont beaucoup plus portés à acheter
local puis acheter des arbres de noël
qui sont faites produit naturellement et
non artificielle donc le jeu pourrait
couper 50 milliards de plus puis je lui
cirais à tous les vents c'est assez
impressionnant présentement la demande
le producteur profite aussi de la forte
demande chez nos voisins du sud
le cocooning qu'impose la pandémie des
deux côtés de la frontière leur ait
particulièrement favorables cette année
beaucoup moins de jacques volland fleury
et j'améliore encore plus de corps à
l'intérieur c'est sûr que c'est d'aider
des échos que j'entends leurs avec talk
producteurs habituellement les
travailleurs agricoles rentrer à la
maison vers la fin octobre
mais cette année parce qu'ils sont
arrivés beaucoup plus tard certains sont
restés plus longtemps
un autre élément positif aux antilles
peut rentabiliser leur séjour ils vont
venir ici puis allongé leur séjour pour
le assez de faire le plus de suppose il
donc on a eu accès un beaucoup plus
grand bassin de transport de
travailleurs pour vous aider à l'air
culture des abonnés et quand on leur
demande de résumer en quelques mots leur
année 2010 très pressant très stressant
pour l'un des dix années les plus dures
que de mes 35 ans des arbres de noël et
ça vaut finir core gamer
à l'opposé ça va être probablement la
meilleure année que j'ai jamais fait
[Musique]
les deux producteurs promettent que leur
sapin contribueront malgré une année
bien particulière à conserver l'esprit
de noël
c'est quand même un produit qui effraie
quand même dingue et et qui sent bon
sentez vous au moins vous sentez le bon
mais réduit on se fait du bien oui où
notre rôle est de bon ton répand le
bonheur qu'on va nous large
[Musique]